what's going on guys this is Rob okay so
we are here with Action Comics and
Superman's deadliest enemy is coming
back here's the thing it's not doomsday
and I feel like some people are gonna be
like what no it's not doomsday but I it
is Superman's deadliest Enemy by far so
here's the thing
picks up with a kind of monologue of
sorts with Lois Lane where she's writing
to a degree about the nature of the city
of metropolis before and after Superman
and she kind of hits it in two different
fronts now this is written by Philip
Kennedy Johnson and it does come off as
war world saga the war world saga is not
really required reading because in this
video I'll basically make sense of the
things that you need to know to
understand what came out of War World to
grasp what's going on here but when she
talks about the nature of metropolis
before and after Superman's arrival the
the before portion is before he ever
even arrived on the scene in the first
place and the second portion or at least
the the second aspect of before he came
back is kind of when he was gone during
the events of war world and now Superman
has effectively returned so as far as
him ever showing up beforehand she only
really hits on it and so far as saying
like Metropolis was kind of a city like
any other right you had levels of crime
you had like governmental corruption
different things like that but Superman
showing up on the scene it wasn't like
the emergence of Bruce Wayne's Batman in
Gotham City where he basically started
cracking down with a kind of Iron Fist
that where Batman is somewhat
dictatorial using fear to basically turn
the direction or determine what
direction Gotham is going to go and
Superman uses hope and so by showing up
here and kind of being a beacon of sorts
and showing Humanity a better way that
what it did is it actually led to Hope
Rising in the city and that people
started getting rid of corrupt political
leaders and they started focusing more
on building the city of metropolis into
a city that was better for everybody
even if it meant that you had to give a
little to get a little right you
couldn't get 100 of what you wanted but
90 is good enough right just the better
men of society and so even when Superman
had basically vanished during the events
of war world saga while you still had
the house of L the other members of the
Superman family which we'll talk about
here in a second at the end of the day
it wasn't Superman and so because it
wasn't him Hope was almost kind of lost
in the city of metropolis but with his
return in the midst of like a protest
and some crazy stuff going on that the
city sort of regains its hope again more
so than that again it's not just
Superman who emerges here it's the whole
house of Elf family now this was Philip
Kennedy Johnson kind of building on one
of the few things that Michael O'Brien
Michael bindis got right in a Superman
run because for the most part he kind of
screwed it all up but one of the cool
things that he did is that in DC Comics
you have different versions of Superman
in some capacity that exist out there
right you've got like Superman himself
you've got Jonathan Kent you have
Supergirl you've got steel you have
Keenan right the Superman of China who's
one of the coolest characters ever in DC
Comics I love him right you've got
Connor Kent right so like the Metropolis
kid is I will always know him and we'll
talk about them a little more over the
course of this video but they were
always kind of scattered and dispersed
right Supergirl was off doing her thing
Conor Kent was on like young justice and
the Titans and you had the Superman of
China who was kind of about doing his
thing John Henry irons had more or less
kind of walked away from the superhero
role after the death and Return of
Superman he kind of lingered for a
little while but had been a background
character for years and years one of the
things been to Sudan is he had
Consolidated it all and he had created
the house of L in the sense that not
only are they all some variation of
Superman in some capacity or at least a
person with Superman type powers that
that's what basically brings them
together in the case of like Kara she's
basically the cousin of Superman so
they're connected by Blood Connor Kent
is the clone of Superman who was created
after Superman was killed at the hands
of Doomsday and then he emerged as the
Metropolis kid and the now famous don't
call me Superboy storyline
right John Henry irons Connor Kent
um The Eradicator cyborg they were all
kind of like the reign of the Superman
so different versions of Superman that
showed up after the main Superman was
killed by doomsday but be whether or not
they're connected by blood or the role
they play they are a kind of family and
and so they operate that way right they
don't I mean they don't go on like crazy
adventures together all the time but
it's always one of those no matter
what's going on one of us will always be
available for anybody that needs our
help now in the midst of all this
pandemonium and these protests and so on
we end up finding metallos there now
here's the thing Metallo to me is
probably the deadliest villain that
Superman has and I know that like
hardcore Superman fans and even hardcore
DC fans will say no that's ridiculous
doomsday is the one that killed him and
that's a fair argument right it's a fair
point to say doomsday is Superman's
deadliest film because he's the one who
killed him but here's the thing doomsday
is a MacGuffin literally the guy's power
is to never die and just grow more
powerful all the time like that's
literally all he is he was a plot device
that was used to launch a story that
basically meant nothing when it was done
with Metallo this guy is basically a
dude who is a walking talking Kryptonite
reactor how do you kill a guy that you
can't touch or at least defeat him and
can't even get all that close to him now
initially that was the way the stories
played out right Metallo and the Silver
age Metallo and the Bronze Age Metallo
in the 90s right and going into the
2000s it was always kind of that way one
of the things that happened is that over
time DC kind of evolved Superman to the
point that he would do like quick passes
at natal right he'd get in and out
really really fast before the Kryptonite
could affect him and then he would also
use different suits of armor and things
along those lines but the reason why I
say Metallo is the deadliest villain of
Superman is because unlike doomsday
where they just Pummel each other that
Superman has to use a combination of his
brain and his Brawn to overcome Metallo
he has to build some kind of suit for
himself or Dawn some kind of a suit he
can't just swoop in and face off against
this guy and so it was a really really
cool moment I mean he'll do it in this
comic because the story demands it but
under any normal circumstance it doesn't
work that way the other part of this is
that Metallo is effectively planning
something more so than that he has this
kind of mental projection that goes on
in his head of Lex Luthor so seemingly
he's working alongside Lex now we'll
find out not everything that's happening
here is as it appears but the kind of
family Dynamic of the House of L comes
home when you have like Superman's
return to Earth being celebrated and you
have him spending time with the family
and they're all like playing card games
and different things like that it's cool
and honestly it looks like the most fun
ever but one of the things that Superman
does is he brings together the entire
family and he says before I left for war
world John asked me a question that I've
thought on every day since he asked why
I don't do more now the reality of this
is when he says John asked me this
question this was back during the very
beginnings of DC rebirth right like
during Frank Thierry and Dan jurgen's
Action Comics Superman run that when
Jonathan was first really kind of
brought into the superhero landscape to
a degree by Superman he would ask all
these questions that we as the fan base
found ourselves asking over the years
but DC just never directly answered and
one of them was exactly this why don't
you do more why are you just a guy that
like whisks in and save somebody or
something like that and so he says I've
always trusted in humanity to find their
way I still do but it's become clear to
me that Earth is in a critical time and
that it is time for us to do more we've
seen alien worlds cultures and
Technologies even alternate Futures
earth needs to see what we've seen and
that's the benefit here is because in a
lot of ways Superman always sort of kept
the crazy space-faring Adventures away
from Earth if for no other reason than
the fact that it was a way to keep Earth
out of danger of super-powered villains
that existed out there but the other
part of that is all the experiences that
he gains the level of technologies that
exist out there now he doesn't doesn't
really intend to like launch this
campaign where it's like we're gonna
make earth more advanced guys and uh
Apple's gonna be the one to do it that's
not really what he's talking about here
but what he is saying is very
reminiscent of the events that we saw
transpire in Silver Surfer Requiem by J
Michael strzinski for those of you guys
who ever read that story it's a
phenomenal story it's like the death of
the Silver Surfer it was amazing uh
we'll go back and remaster it because I
love that story but the thing about it
is that there comes a point when Peter
Parker Spider-Man ends up encountering
the Silver Surfer and the surfer I don't
remember if he tells Peter that he's
dying or if Peter picks it up or maybe
it's just never spoken but he tells
Peter he'll give him a gift and so what
Peter does is he actually extends the
gift to humanity and he says show the
human race exactly what makes us special
and unique and so for a moment the
Silver Surfer provides Humanity with
Cosmic awareness they become completely
aware of their place within the entirety
of the universe and while we don't
necessarily find the full fruition of
that what's basically indicated is that
it unites Humanity in a way that was
never perceived possible before because
they realize how fragile humanity is but
also everything that can be accomplished
and so while of course Superman's not
going to Grant the entirety of him of
the human race on Earth Cosmic awareness
it is one of those things where it's
bringing the benefits of this
technological experience out in Space
the things of Kryptonian technology and
so on and so forth bringing that kind of
advancement to humanity more so than
that what he also does is he introduces
Ortho and or so raw now these are two
characters that came from the war world
storyline and that's the thing so the
whole idea behind war world is that it's
basically led by Mongol and then
essentially his offspring but war world
is itself literally a floating Planet it
just exists out there it's a whole world
now they do have an actual race of what
are kind of like DC's Spartans to a
degree albeit more self-interested and
less focused on like an organized
Society but they're incredibly powerful
and they serve as kind of a police force
invading Army so what will happen is
that Mongol or any one of his
descendants will show up to a world
right his army will descend on that
world they'll destroy anybody who
resists and they'll enslave the rest
strip the planet of its resources and
then those who are enslaved will will
then become basically gladiatorial
people on war world now what also
happens there and especially in the case
of these two kids their entire family
was killed but they were too young to
truly understand what was going on so
they were quite literally raised on war
world and so like so many other people
who are either conditioned to do it or
who don't know anything else because
they were young when they were captured
they came to view Mongol as almost their
kind of God and their goal was to
basically achieve his satisfaction right
to basically say like we want you to
approve of us and that fighting in the
arena and working their way up the ranks
was the best way to do it now Superman
being stuck on war world because there
was Red Sun radiation he didn't have any
powers and in fact there was a point
where he could have potentially been
rescued but he shot the option down
because what he wanted to do was
basically foam Insurrection he wanted to
lead the people of War World against
their governing body overthrow it and
rebel which was actually really cool
right Superman became an insurrectionist
it was kind of amazing but the thing
about this is that It ultimately led to
Superman bringing these two kids back to
Earth and then adopting them because
they're incredibly capable in fact they
kind of go by the name the super twins
at the moment they're like the most fun
ever they're amazing like I love reading
about them but they're kind of being
added to the Superman family in the
house of el to a degree they are young
so they don't necessarily get all the
experience and everything that goes
along with it but what ends up happening
here is that by way of Metallo's
intervention and his actions when John
Henry irons and his daughter end up
basically initiating this grand plan to
basically launch steelworks which will
serve as a kind of technological Beacon
and will focus on building uh really
Advanced Technologies that can be used
within the city of metropolis to improve
everybody's life that Metallo makes his
makes his move right he attacks
steelworks now the idea here at least
according to the vision from Lex Luthor
is that Lex wants Metallo to do it
because Lex Luthor wants to be the one
to decide what direction Metropolis goes
in right it's the most basic Lex Luthor
plot ever and that in order to make it
happen Lex Luthor has taken the sister
of Metallo and is threatening to kill
her if he doesn't do it that's kind of
the crazy thing but again not everything
is what it appears to be and so Metallo
launches an attack now Conor Kent is the
one that spots Metallo but doesn't
initially recognize him instead he goes
up to investigate what's going on and
the metado blasts him with Kryptonite
radiation which is enough to take Connor
kid out and the Metallo basically starts
to destroy the building now of course
Superman and these guys are able to
respond and that's the nature of
Superman's Evolution over time when he's
dealing with Metallo because notice this
even though he hears his voice and he
doesn't initially know that it's him
once he figures it out he initially
keeps his distance he doesn't just go
running up to Metallo in like attacking
because as a guy who's basically
emitting green Kryptonite radiation
Superman can't linger for long and so
that's why you see him staying a kind of
little bit of distance away and then
figuring out how best to take this guy
out and then launching into the attack
now the other benefit here and this is
the reason why the house of L is so cool
is because Superman is vulnerable to
Green Kryptonite radiation Supergirl is
vulnerable to it Conor Kent's vulnerable
to it John Henry irons and his daughter
are not and so they immediately go on
the attack and so despite how kibble
monitolo is and even though he's able to
hold his own against these guys they're
able to injure him enough to where
Superman can immediately swoop in frees
this guy up and toss him into space and
that's it right like you have to deal
with him as fast as humanly possible
Superman cannot let a fight between
himself and Metallo drag out because if
it happens Metallo will overcome him and
he will kill him because he literally is
a walking talking green Kryptonite
reactor right he's literally powered by
Green Kryptonite it's kind of nuts and
so what happens is that when one of the
kids ask who Metallo is right this guy
who's one of Superman's most capable
villains that John Henry irons offers a
kind of extra explanation and the one
that we get I mean it is good enough to
understand the character in the moment
right if you just want to understand the
base nature of him but he basically says
that like you know Metallo was a soldier
who volunteered for the SEAL soldier
program a defense program that both Lex
Luthor and even John Henry irons had
developed but he says they rushed it
through and there were complications and
that John Corbin's body basically didn't
survive and so in essence his mind is
there but his body is basically a kind
of robot this powered by Green
Kryptonite which makes him kind of the
ultimate anti-superman but one of the
things that's cool here is that the two
kids really kind of throw in the idea
that he sounds like an unmade now before
the events of Philip Kennedy Johnson's
War World this is a concept that never
would have crossed our mind before but
the unmade are basically Undead cyborgs
right people who have by all standards a
measurement been killed but using a
combination of necromancy and Technology
the forces of war world can bring them
back from the dead but in like a
cybernetic body and then they just kind
of go forward as henchmen of Mongol and
so this almost perfectly describes the
nature of Metallo which really gives me
cause to believe that like what Philip
Kennedy Johnson is doing is kind of
elevating the role that Metallo
traditionally has changing up the nature
of his character instead of him just
kind of being a dude out there that
emits green Kryptonite and like fights
Superman and win sometimes I guess that
instead he's actually changing the
nature of him and evolving him into
something else now this all comes home
to roost when Superman and the family
are all just kind of sitting around
after the kids are put to bed and
they're pondering everything going on
with Metallo and what Superman says is
that there was a moment in the fight
when Metallo seemed to be speaking to
Luther but one of the things that
Superman had done is that in the moment
he had used his x-ray vision to see what
Luther was doing and Luther's in jail
he's been in jail for quite some time
that maybe he potentially had a hand in
matalo's Escape but but it seems highly
unlikely and so whoever it is that
Metallo is talking to you it's not Lex
Luthor and that's why the idea of the
unmade seems more and more prominent
because the nature of the unmade is yes
they're incredibly powerful yes they are
for the most part every bit as capable
as Superman traditionally is depending
on what level of power he has in the
story that's being written but they
follow orders they do what they're told
and so someone out there is telling them
what to do seemingly someone is telling
Metallo what to do and that where Lex
Luthor it almost kind of given metallic
instruction destroys steel works and
like you have to defeat Superman or
something like that as he's out there in
space suddenly the vision of his sister
pops up and it's almost a carrot on a
stick right where his where he's like
hey you know I I destroyed steelworks
Lex Luthor is gonna free you now she's
like well I mean it's not that simple
anymore see like when you when you
defeated Superman uh Superman took me
prisoner right so now he's got me held
in a prison somewhere so the only way to
free me is you have to kill Superman
right it's like we'll do this and then
everything will be okay and then once
that thing is done well no no we have to
do this now right so whoever it is
that's controlling him always kind of
has him running like a gerbil on a
hamster wheel right like it's always
never ever good enough he's gonna have
to keep finding a way to destroy
Superman in order to free his sister
which most likely is not even being held
captured or anything in any capacity so
that's when they kind of look at this
and they're like there's something much
bigger going on here who's pulling the
strings and who it is who is it that's
trying to like destroy us and Destroy
steel works and even kill me as Superman
most likely it's somebody from war world
and so what ends up happening is Metallo
travels back to Earth and then snatches
up some Blue Earth protester now the
Blue Earth protesters are one part I
wouldn't really call them like nature or
in vinyl middle protesters they're more
like people who are like Earth is for
humans and no one else that kind of a
thing so like shutting Superman like we
don't want aliens here or anything like
that they've they've operated by
different names and DC Comics over the
years but the general concept of a group
out there protesting the presence of
Superman that's been going on for
decades right like ever since I would
argue the more weissinger years in DC
Comics in the 1950s back when he was
editing everything right Kurt Swan and
all those guys so the thing about this
is that Metallo's showing up here
basically tells these guys okay so like
as Blue Earth protesters you guys
obviously hate Superman but let's let's
let's really put some skin in the game
right like right now you're standing on
a street corner with signs let's see
what metal you really have are you
willing to put up or shut up are you
gonna put your money where your mouth is
so he's like I'm gonna take you guys and
I'm gonna turn you into exactly what you
want to be you would hate Superman so
much I'm gonna give you the power to
destroy him now what ends up going on
here is when he takes these guys
snatches them up and brings them back to
his base of operations well then we see
what metal they really have and they
don't have much right they're just kind
of like well I mean no no all we want to
do is protest you know we don't actually
want to do anything right they're like
Twitter users and Reddit users right
they don't actually want to do anything
they just want to look like they're
doing something and so what ends up
happening here is he just forces them
into it anyway what he says is he's
basically going to strip them down and
he's going to turn them right eradicate
them in their current form and turn them
into basically unmade people like him
he's building his own anti-superman Army
which is amazing I got to tell you guys
this is the most interesting Metallo has
ever been and it's not even just this
guy that DC is doing it with they're
doing it with metamorpho they're doing
it with a meso they're taking like all
these villains that have historically
been maybe like b-list or potentially
c-less villains as underrated as a lot
of them are and they're elevating them
up to insane levels because I'm going to
tell you guys right now in Batman
Superman world's finest which we will
cover uh metamorpho well kind of
technically it's Ultra Ultra Morpho that
guy just demolished Batman and Superman
and not even by a little bit like crush
them it was crazy but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later
peace